I've come to South Korea to meet someone
who came here to find a better future in
2009 she escaped from North Korea and
has started a new life here and so high
that means you and you'll know kyon
lives in an apartment paid for by the
South Korean government it's small but
she's tried to make it feel like home
when she left North Korea she couldn't
take any of her belongings with her
thank you in order to protect their
families in North Korea many defectors
change their names kyon is in your name
as well now i'm in da Gama Hungama sir I
so uno duo cool what don't get a hot
thought I was in oven in there whoa
don't get a powder than anything I threw
the rock like a children's character
drinking even more taco to whom devote
an entire ham song okay bow me in
navarre so couldnt can turn it on it
over sin no matter so sometimes urbana
man who now get on ba dungeons are
immoral man money para la San Mateo with
the cookies on antic onward kyon is one
of 25,000 North Korean defectors living
in South Korea the most common escape
route is through China since crossing
the border that separates the two Koreas
is nearly impossible there are so many
a half hours drive north of Seoul I get
my first glimpse of the electrified
fence by defecting Cayenne thought she
could help her family financially what
she didn't know was that once she
crossed the border there would be no
turning back and no safe way to contact
her family
to my surprise the border is a big
tourist attraction as well a lot of tour
groups and school classes come here
every day it's the closest kyon has come
to north korea since the day she left
Gaza Hamas around 11 and a moo to move
on our trees around a magnetar dr.
Dubrow need to load seneca college ave
to take some will Monica Dogra honey
will have sweet it feels weird standing
here looking down on the most isolated
country in the world I wonder how this
perky on seeing her home country right
across the river from this honor now for
money to give a kiss Jessica so if I
want imran persistent okay fair enough
energy to go to go a single again Oh to
Tiana not a single bond has two
cavatelli enemy you looked and Lizzie
levantas in some non dodoma jihadi
taranay would egos or to Tanana than a
single vanity
every year around two to three thousand
North Koreans defect to the south in the
last two years that number has gone down
due to stricter controls on North
Korea's border to China the buffer zone
between the two countries stretches on
for 250 kilometers the so-called
Demilitarized Zone despite the name it's
the most heavily armed border in the
world and a popular sightseeing
destination at least on this side
the yum yum school and soul is a special
school for North Korean defectors most
of the students have a lot of catching
up to do when they arrived in South
Korea in order to keep up with the
highly competitive education system the
school prepares them for university life
and South Korean life in general
traditional classroom mobile school many
of the students are traumatized they've
left their relatives behind us and have
no family to depend on here redundant we
don't want to make them leave like if
they wanted to oh yeah that's right they
don't like to show their face you're
gonna go beside you the school tries to
give them a sense of security as well as
teach them things they're not used to
like making their own decisions or
speaking up for themselves koo koo roo
boon nah man sir andrew tiernan
compressor han saram easy man chrisman
crack a dupes in Rudi Reggie boo Darin
Joe Kuhn toward jordan and kareem in
sick to go to catherine Doozer Creek a
single Canyon saw sanguillen at an
imagined top Comerica anime enlightened
John chagum you don't get mr cocky
Damita
Kyon's way of coping with her struggles
is playing basketball and writing poems
she didn't go to a special school she
studied hard and got a scholarship for
one of the top universities and soul but
she still has a tough time adapting to a
whole different system and making
friends at university don't work 10
miles of the one who took it easy on
your car so but a tailgate or talked
about in Moodle is an eye on boat
huggies augustinian birthday so I
suggest a hip hop around to 27 women dig
this one go giggle but i'm not using
your tail this to got sweet sinner don't
give me that I'm an Aussie tale bout in
de la mano in Davao van jager has a
seagull they take a helper ocotillo wkq
gets wouldn't still she feels isolated
on campus at 27 k owns a lot older than
her classmates in Korean culture all the
people usually pay for the younger
friends food and drink since she doesn't
have much money it's another obstacle
holding her back
during my visit to Korea everyone is
preparing for Chizik a harvest festival
and massive three-day celebration during
this national holiday Koreans travel to
their ancestral villages gather with
their families and share traditional
food foci on this time of year is
especially hard one essential part of
the celebration is the traditional dress
the women wear when they go to see their
families the humbug it's the first time
kyon has ever worn one since she never
had enough money to buy a handbook in
North Korea how would your mother react
if she would see you like this take a it
isn't anybody's husband with and I am
mando a party on college no real humble
do give colossal poses a particle to
Obama passenger car & sinker
while others are preparing the
traditional feast and setting our
pictures of family members kyon visits a
Buddhist temple she praised her mother
not to starve so that one day they can
meet again kyon hopes that North and
South Korea was someday be reunited it's
the one thing that keeps her going and
makes it possible for her to adapt to
her new life in the south I can eat our
ability and I think I am cardo get on my
case to the captain and don't do
anything on Rakatan you and the two
necessity I saw see Monica gets high
season do it again oh okay who took a
pass get part on the apogee pass your
car on a to do miss her solicitor their
canes overall despite her difficulties
kyon appreciates that here in the south
at least she has a chance to figure out
who she is and I wish that one day
she'll be able to share that with her
family
No